[Music]
good morning everyone it's joanna here
i'm not sure if you can see this but i'm
actually in my pajamas because today we
want to do this workout first thing in
the morning in your pajamas only seven
exercises seven minutes and i want you
to do this workout before you shower
before you have your breakfast to
kick-start your metabolism to burn fat
and to keep you energized throughout the
day what you'll need is one or two
similar weight dumbbells so let's start
so set your timer to 7 minutes 50
seconds and 10 seconds interval okay
let's start
with the first workout which is squats
it is the best way to work on the major
muscles okay now squat one
open white
back to narrow squat
wide
and now i want you to do five pulses
okay good
white
narrow so you're really targeting your
legs and your bum muscles one two three
four five what a great way to start your
morning keep going narrow
white five pulses go low two three four
five good job
one
narrow
doing well
this will really awake your muscles and
to burn
fat good keep going
you're almost there
should feel your heartbreak starting to
go up
let's go one more
narrow
and rest second workout push up and
rotate so now we want to work on our
upper body and also on our sides
ready down on the floor push up
and rotate okay
opposite side push up
and rotate good
assuming that
you know we won't be wearing any bra
all these workouts are low impact
good keep going
rotate
make sure you're twisting your torso
good keep
going push up
and rotate
[Music]
very nice
if you find this challenging again
beginners you can always start
on your knees
very very good rotate
push up is so simple i mean it's not
simple it's basic but it is
the best
upper body and tools the body workout
rest
third workout lunge and twist so i want
you to grab one down now
okay step at the edge
lunge forward
and twist to the right side step back
lunge forward extend your arms and twist
again we are working on multiple muscles
your lower legs
and your torso and also your arms by
extending it forward
very nice
good
so if you do this first thing in the
morning
there is no reason
for you not to do your workout
throughout the day
very good
halfway there
keep going
extend all the way twist
tuck in your tummy
feel the abs working
twist
good job
twist
let's do two more
one
twist and rest
next workout
going back to our upper body dips and
kicks
so down onto the back
i want
you to dip and kick it up okay
so again we are working on the triceps
and also with the kicks you will feel
your butt and your hamstrings working so
make sure you're going low
control don't rush it nice and control
and kick it as high up as you can good
okay
so all these workout
are
sort of like you don't have to wear your
bra or any sports bra to do this workout
because it is really low impact
at the same time it is going to raise
your heart rate
and to kick start your metabolism
i'm sure you can hear me painting right
now
keep going
feel more deep and cake up good up
very good
last one
rest
next workout for this workout you can
choose to hold one dumbbell or two
dumbbell
this is basically dumbbell swing
stand white down and swing it up okay
so you are working on the inner thighs
and your core and your lower back at the
same time
i want you to push and swing with your
torso not with your arms swing
okay and push with your torso good
keep going
up
very good
swing it up
using your lower back
and your abs string the dumbbells all
the way up
keep going stand wide
do your inner thighs at the same time
and you're doing good
breathe
keep going
five minutes down
two minutes to go after this very good
one more
good
now
down onto the map
we are going to focus on our abs
so just like russian twist
lips up i want you to cross over bring
the weights over
and cross it over okay
so bring your lower butt your upper body
slightly lower down
and then extend your legs bring the
dumbbells over
and cross it
just like this nice and controlled
good job keep going
so you should feel your abs working as
you are trying to maintain this position
and your lower abs working at the same
time
keep going
halfway there extend
good
cross it over
if you want to
you can carry a heavier thumbnail
or
increase
the speed
good almost there
[Music]
and rest
final workout will be one minute of
plank okay
so get into your peg
position
and just hold it for 20 seconds
okay
just a steady plank
hold it for 20 seconds
good make sure you're tightening your
core your abs
no arching no overextending
nice and tight
and just breathe
20 seconds down
and now i want you to move
back and forth
for 20 seconds
and maintain the position
very good keep going
back and forth
maintain the plank position
keep going almost there
five more seconds
back and forth
and now
just hold it for the rest
of your remaining 10 seconds
very good tighten your core
stay focused
you are almost there you are almost done
three more seconds
and rest
stretch it out
you have 27 minutes morning workout in
your pajamas
and now you can kick start your day
stretch forward and just relax
so guys you should be sweating slightly
you should feel your heart rate pumping
and you should feel more awake and
energized if you know you have a busy
day ahead and you do not have any time
to fit in a full workout session then do
this workout first thing in the morning
and you will not have any excuses to
turn this into a full workout session
repeat the entire circuit two to three
more times and as you progress increase
the weight's use increase the workout
time and reduce the rest time you do not
need any special workout outfit just
work out in your pajamas and share me
your workout picture all the best
for new fitness food and motivational
videos please like share and subscribe
to my youtube channel and website
do follow me on facebook instagram and
twitter to stay connected with me thanks
guys
[Music]
you